sounds great we do do out of my way and
we're starting our energy off with the
dill out of my way I'm waiting Sonny and
Cher we have a whole castle oh no was
this what it was on set yeah well this
we're going this is full-on great stuff
this is full-on already in hysterics I'm
having to calm down yeah down is a I was
just saying to him he's one of the
funniest people I've ever met if he
helped you know throws the whole
directing thing and I think you should
you should definitely look at Donna I'm
gonna do stand-up
yeah was that like a $5 or $20 bill to
get her to say that my shill shirt for
people that don't realize before we go
any further I have to say a huge thank
you to Kelly Kia Telluride for being our
sponsor the only reason we get to be
here at Sundance it's very expensive to
be here and key has been a great sponsor
and I really want to give them a sincere
thank you
and now let's jump what do I get to talk
to you guys so it's the day before your
world premiere at Sundance
no one's seen the movie are you [ __ ]
bullets or are you super excited super
excited for people to see the film
absolutely we made the film we wanted to
make and Netflix supporters creatively
artistically financially it's rare to be
able to take something that that that
that is a little out of the box and
unusual and and pursue it the way we did
and we're really happy with our film and
very excited to be able to sue I hate
asking this question but most people
will not have seen it by the time
they're watching this interview can you
talk about the character you play and
and how have you been describing the
film to friends
I play a character called Josefina which
comes straight out of Dan Gilroy's
brilliant and very can I say strange
mind was the twisted mind she
is she's the person that kind of kicks
off our story in a lot of ways and it's
a huge incredible ensemble as you were
saying you know there's actor John
Malkovich Toni Collette Rene Russo John
I mean it's a sprawling piece so what's
really lovely is she's kind of the
catalyst for where the plot ends up
going she's a very frustrated gallery
assistant to Rene Russo's gallery owner
and how would you say to she she sees as
an opportunity she finds a man how much
can I say she finds a man dead in her
apartment block she goes into his
apartment she sees that he has hoarded a
lot of incredible art that instantly has
a very magical strange effect and so she
decides to take the art and attempt to
sort of posthumously produce him and
exhibit him as you know one of the
greatest artists of our time is
intercepted by Rene is intercepted by
Jake as an art critic and slowly the art
starts to show what its true magical
satanic power is no satanic but you know
it's a dark element to it yeah I cannot
effing wait to see this I'm so excited
to realize that in the art world do you
think that what is ready for this I'm
also I mean I love looking at art and I
love damn you you know it's there's not
that many movies that take place in the
art world it's not a you know it's not
overexposed if you will talk a little
bit about weird where did the idea for
this come from are you like at a museum
one day and you start having thoughts I
was in a Contemporary Art Museum
two days after Christmas a couple years
ago and I was down in the basement
there's a video exhibit dentist chairs
rats running around I just thought this
would be a great place for a thriller
slash horror movie but it's not the only
reason why I did it because I am always
been very interested in art and commerce
and the intersection of it and I think
right now the relationship is a very
rocky one I don't think you can judge
the quality of a piece by the number of
views or or the pricetag success doesn't
define a piece but it
it distracts a little bit from the
intent so when I realized that to the
theme and the world could be put
together in the film that's when I took
off with it how did you decide the art
that you find in the apartment obviously
needs to hit people it needs to take
them or transport them how did you
decide on what art was gonna be there to
you know be the stuff that people
respond to all right there were some
people who read this script that thought
that was the biggest hurdle that we had
to cross was to make the art believable
and I feel that was in some way so a
year before I hired somebody who's
fairly well-known in the contemporary
art world
David Hundley he became our art advisor
and for a year we tried different
artists we created pieces we coded over
100 pieces of art for the film and it
took that took well over half a year to
do it so we've invested a lot of time in
when you do something like that does he
get ownership of the art or to do as
Netflix now own it right now David and I
share ownership of the art afterward and
that was something that we negotiated
and Netflix was open to it so actually a
lot of the arts gonna be at the party
after the premiere in LA so the love is
gonna be on display but you know it was
so amazing about the art when you were
in scenes with it or you know trying to
prepare your character in relation to
the art and this amazing magical
supernatural thing that supposed to
happen when you look at it it became
less and less and less about the are as
we went on
do you remember because suddenly the art
was about what people were projecting
onto it so the art was central visceral
thing that drives the film but actually
became more about what each person sees
in them SAP you know seasoned themself
when they look at me are and how it sort
of takes them over in a way which was
just the cleverest thing and yeah I'm
curious in the writing process how much
are you writing knowing that you want to
put certain actors in these roles do you
know me because you have that
relationship with Jake I heard you might
have a relationship with Renee you know
I used to we broke up we didn't break up
it's gonna be like this interview you're
finding about it
on an interview I'm sorry it's better
than a text I really thought I stepped
on a third rail there and I'm so happy I
didn't but no seriously what were you
writing with these people in mind or how
much is it you're just writing the
script and then maybe rewriting once you
find certain actors that I wrote the
script I wrote Jake's part for Jake
Renee's boyfriend a-and I had we have a
Robert Altman like ensemble cast there
really is a Robert Altman feeling sort
of like the play or a Nashville that's a
big part of movie cast and the problem
when you start off with Jake and Renee
the bar is so high that that rounding
out the rest of the cast becomes
difficult
so findings away you know Billy for the
part Natalia Dyer Tom Sturridge it it
took three months longer to cast this
part because we were just so picky and
finicky and Zoe is amazing that way is
an amazing person in the film amazing
actor in the film it's so creative I've
started watching some of your short
films they're so good you should be
she's writing directing I think she's
gonna be a writer director in the future
in addition to acting and and I like
working with really creative people and
so he fits right in there
with it a 5 or 20 dollar bill there's no
money exchanging hands here my money's
changing a collaboration what's amazing
with Dan's work is you only you only
need to read a little bit of it for it
to really get under your skin so in
terms of the audition process that I had
it was very it was very simple I did a
tape I had very few scenes I didn't have
a whole script and I put it on tape and
as I started to do it something I don't
know he's weird
something just starts to take you over
you read it and you go oh these are the
sizes a really epic and beautifully
written but you can't sense necessarily
what the atmosphere of them is and the
honesty it took me over in a matter of
scene so the fact that I'm even here
having done the film and being involved
is just it's just amazing because it's
some of the best writing that I've ever
experienced
I'm very curious with the how much for
you changes onset and how much is it you
know you're very much watching the
commas you know what I mean no I'm not
watching the commas I think the actors
come in and
the words but I I don't have a problem
with somebody changing certain words
here or there or I just lost the idea of
its coming through I want ownership of
the actor I want they actually take
ownership of the parts and from every
aspect so if that includes changing a
word here and there what in the midst of
a scene what they do is so incredibly
difficult I'm not gonna go it didn't
raise say the rights of line it was
either people can change lines and words
that's okay so has the intent is there
well like we were open I was at my phone
I'm really sorry sorry it's my mom
calling me she's like she's like did you
fall in the snow mm cut the cord
it was amazing because you would be on
set and maybe want to change a line and
then as soon as you did and you did the
tape you're like oh god no don't put the
line back but you would let people do it
we are built pretty tightly together
well it's just it's just there is a real
flow and there is a real atmosphere and
some of the lines that Dan's written
everyone wanted to say like I remember
when Jake and I were doing scenes and he
just be like I can't wait to say this
line because it's so brilliantly built
um like critique is so limiting and
emotion he dreaming that's what I think
it's about memes already you know so
Netflix is actually pretty good at memes
they drive yeah exactly I think a lot of
people don't realize that when you are
putting stuff though they actually help
sell a movie I have gifts and memes and
all that stuff it really actually works
they this Netflix company I think it's
gonna land on their feet pretty
confident yeah yeah but I actually want
to ask see they greenlight the movie
how much changes from you working with
them and saying okay we're gonna make it
to what people are seeing on screen you
know talk a little bit about the
collaboration with them Netflix is
artist friendly they want creative
people there they want to support the
vision of creative people it's it's a
very unique place to work at and it's a
very unique time right now there's very
few places that you go in and and say I
want to take chances on this and this
and and try this that you'll get full
support I got that from from Ted Saran
DOS down to Scott Stuber to call him
everybody at Netflix has been supported
his film it did not really change too
much from the
script and I think if there was the
biggest change probably came in the
editing room where we were really sort
of tinkering with the tone of the movie
because it's a mix onre film there's
there's there's humor there is drama
there is thrills there are ideas so at
any given moment the film we were
dialing and what we wanted to know make
sure they knew that we knew where we
were with our genre but apart from that
Netflix is just utterly supportive of
they want to work with artists they want
to work with people who want to make
unique and interesting films and it's a
joy to work with Netflix that actually
brings to the editing process and I've
said this again and again is ultimately
the final rewrite so I am curious how
the film changed in the editing room
what you learned from early screenings
and when did you actually see it I still
haven't seen the movie if I can even
drum up the courage to watch it yeah I'm
bad at watching myself at the best of
times but what I've seen so far is has
above and beyond exceeded my
expectations and in terms of what change
I I look at a story as as an armature
sort of like a Christmas tree and I want
to hang as many ideas on it as possible
because I there's so many things I want
to say I mean I make films because it's
such an incredible medium to get ideas
out into the world and I just want to
transfer the ideas and I think in the
cutting room there was just certain
ideas that just it was I didn't need
that ornament so the armature didn't
need that there was a line jake has a
line one time that I love this line what
if what if what people see isn't what
they want it's what we feed them as a
critic and I still wanted that line to
get in there but I was like in the
middle it seems like it just doesn't it
does no bearing of what's going on and
this probably like a dozen lines like
that that didn't make the cut there were
musical choices that we had to dial in
different you know Marco Beltrami did
our music and didn't agree credible job
and marco was changing the score up
until sort of toward the end but he's
kind of talented yeah marco is amazing
yeah I want to switch gears and we're
gonna play something called get to know
your Sundance attendee I promise these
are harmless questions what TV show
would you love to guest star on and what
TV show would you love to guest write
and direct okay I'm gonna pick something
that's a bit weird because it's not
really a show it's kind of like it's not
a drama or anything but
I'm really desperate to be on or
involved with RuPaul's Drag Race in any
way it's well I don't know what what
that means necessarily whether that's me
doing the drag I don't think they would
go for that me actually being part of
the drag competitors but if I could just
be on that maybe as an assistant or I
don't know like a co-anchor or something
I think that would be great I want to be
one of the judges on the British baking
show now for the food but its life seems
so nice and of intent like it's just
seems so everything seems to so say like
nothing bad could happen when you're
judging the ten I hear something I hear
that but I'm also curious to like see
your take on like the good place or you
know because you have an interesting you
write some interesting stuff so I'm just
curious about some you know are you
watching
I don't know anything from you know
better call Saul to Game of Thrones to
you name it uh you know one of the
things I really enjoyed this year was
Ben Stiller's escape from Dannemora sure
I was blown away by what Ben did and if
Ben's watching I'm a hats off man it's
like you crushed that thing the acting
the directing I think it's a real work
of art what Ben did and it's a limited
series at seven parts a two-storey but I
think that's something that I mean I to
be honest I don't want I don't watch a
tremendous amount of like television in
general but but uh but no I thought Ben
did a great job I would've been proud to
be a part of that do you have a favorite
sci-fi or fantasy film
I'm not a huge sci-fi person but the
ones that I do love I love very very
deeply
yeah I think I'd have to go with Blade
Runner because I watched it probably
when I was way too young and I feel like
it did cognitively like form part of my
personality somewhere along the line I
love fantasy and my favorite film is has
always been the Wizard of Oz and my
favorite film is always at that movie
has everything everything that movie has
heart forever
it's got fantasy it's got characters
it's got a message your your auntie em
thank you but you know it was so funny I
saw once a breakdown of it I think in
like a TV Guide or something that was
like The Wizard of Oz and instead of a
girl goes on a magical adventure it was
like a young woman meets like three
strangers in The Saturdays for an hour
and a half
what films scared you as a kid well The
Wizard of Oz terrified me those frickin
flying monkeys are the most terrifying
images of all time yeah I'm the mean
trees it means rays I mean in yeah
that's right I phone right there yeah I
mean I mean it's the stupid slasher
movies no no those I really can't frame
I mean for like scary imagery we got
that too is there anything that you
collect I am NOT a collector I don't I
don't have really too much stuff
I collect key cards from hotels I say
sure I know same that's cool but I do
the same thing so we're both doing
illegally yeah but I do also I have to
say I worked as an usher for seven years
and an independence in tomorrow in
London and I have collected I would say
every movie stub of every film I've seen
since I was like 18 I've also done that
I don't hear these the answer is too
often except for people who have the
same diseases may
what do you remember your first movie or
TV show crush oh the first I think I was
probably inappropriately significantly
older than you Mary Ann on Gilligan's
Island I had a crush on her I did oh and
also the Brady Bunch
the middle the middle sister Jan Jan I
had a crush on Jim if you're out there
Jan I think do you know what's really
weird I feel like my first crush was
maybe on a like a cartoon animal I feel
like that was a safe space to start
fancying you know boys maybe you know
like animation
I really had a crush on the dog Charlie
from all dogs go to heaven the animation
Inc Jamie Dornan told me that his first
crush was the girl the female in Robin
Hood the animated for the Fox yeah so
you know but you know also I think I had
a crush on [ __ ] from lady in the [ __ ]
I mean he was just sassy he was doing
his own thing Patera way Renee's first
crush was on a superhero you guys
probably haven't in in England was
Mighty Mouse first question was Mighty
Mouse in soro the original Zora Wow she
wound up with me combination do you own
any movie or TV show props I have a lot
of clothes from a show which is on
Netflix now that I did four years in the
UK called fresh meat so I have a lot of
clothes I don't know if I have any props
I think that kind of counts though you
borrowed some stuff yeah I took there
were some jeans that I had graffiti'd
slowly from like season 1 to season 4
which are kind of a cool memento I kept
Jake's watching Nightcrawler that he
would mugged the guy for and I kept and
roman newsreel I kept denzel's heavy
briefcase and I have both of those in my
office I like that
background photo on your phone
my mom and dad oh I have a photo I lost
my phone and the day that Jake said he
was gonna do Nightcrawler
I got a new phone and I walked that side
and I took a picture of a rainbow and
I've always had that on on my phone
that's awesome what TV show if you watch
all the way through more than once if
you have because I know you don't watch
a lot of TV definitely have because I do
get obsessive like that and I kind of mm
Cheers maybe sure I Sopranos these are
three called like this or that just
curious which one you're more into Star
Wars or Star Trek I've never seen a
Sowell's that's Star Trek Star Trek
right no I'd like to have seen one but I
think I'm most Star Trek a game of
Thrones or Breaking Bad Breaking bags
I've never seen Game of Thrones Breaking
Bad cuz I've never seen Game of Thrones
either Wow we also like forever I
already know what the answer on this one
is for you but Han Solo or Indiana Jones
Indiana Jones all the way the rickety
bridge come on Indiana Jones there's my
last thing for you I'm always curious
how people if you remember what got you
into the entertainment industry is like
a younger as a kid did you see a movie
or a performance and say oh my god I
want to be involved in that I got
involved my first professional job when
I was six so I don't know if it was
necessarily conscious and maybe it was
just like having undiagnosed kind of
hyperactive issues whereby I just had to
do loads of different hobbies and then I
just gradually settled on one but I feel
like the first day I walked into the
drama class that I did when I was six I
saw three baskets labeled wigs masks and
costumes and I just kind of knew but I
was supposed to do whatever that was I
consider myself more of a writer than a
director so I was in college
and I taken a term off and I was in
Athens and I got in brutally drunk one
night punched out my best friend and
lost my passport and I was sitting in a
bar at six o'clock in the morning cuz I
had no place to stay and and and I had
to hint I had to write something for
this creative writing class I wanted to
get into so brutally hungover I wrote
this like three page short story and I
was like oh my god like I know how to do
this like I first I never tried to write
I think I was like 19 and it was like
that's when I thought I know how to do
this which is odd
yeah the rail tail thought I was gonna
say that's a crazy story and and I loved
it in a perfect way to end the interview
I'm gonna say sincerely I cannot wait to
see the movie I will be there tomorrow
night and I sincerely say thank you for
coming in our studio thanks for having
us thanks to all that kahlúa
you